what are you looking for exactly like
you want some guy to come
come over and pick you up and throw you
around or beat you up or something like
what are you looking for
um no i just i just noticed whenever
my father leaves out kind of loose and
lack
focus on my goals in life stuff like
that
and i just don't i see myself right now
okay so
he here's here's the here's the thing i
look
you could my my role model was john
mcclane
okay and i was going to save terrorists
or kill terrorists at nakatomi plaza
and be the hero um you're
you're looking the wrong way for a role
model
because i think especially most young
men today are going to have to raise
themselves
and it's not a role model or somebody
you know if you want a role model go
watch steve mcqueen movies or
uh you know worship the great lord and
our savior abu
bruce willis uh but in the end it's
you know i was i was 17 and i made a
decision i was gonna be a whiny little
[ __ ]
and i was like gonna go and do my own
thing and make my own money and that's
what it is and sometimes you just gotta
you gotta raise yourself and it's not
that hard you you'll you'll have your
own role model you'll form your own self
uh just merely supporting yourself and
surviving
you'll you'll get the hard school of
knox which is gonna
teach you more than any role model could
but as long as you
don't get a girl pregnant don't major in
stupid crap
and don't commit no crimes you'll you'll
do fine
and you'll have and it's not it's not
that hard to figure it out so
when you get older there might be some
more esoteric
existential questions like what is the
point and purpose of life
but you know as a 17 year old you're a
little [ __ ] and you live with your mom
okay
now when you're 18 you don't live with
mom okay now you're a man
and that alone right there that trial
and tribulation of paying your own rent
and supporting yourself that's going to
give you your own
uh male role model uh without being a
a codified entity um but i
i would recommend bruce wills as a role
model and ronald reagan
um steve mcqueen's pretty cool too but
no just uh you don't you don't need a
role model you just need to support
yourself
which is coming at the age of anything
with like combat sports you
you know you work out at a dojo or
anything like that um yeah i go to ufc
gym me and my brother do jiu jitsu
a bunch of martial arts and stuff like
that good and i do have your book rich
uh halfway through now it's pretty
awesome i hope you enjoy it do me a
do me a solid and leave a nice review on
amazon when you're done too
um yeah just just keep doing what you're
doing man don't worry the old man's
gonna be back don't let your mom
feminize you or try to
mess you or anything like that just you
know just do your own thing keep walking
around with your shirt off and you know
be the man that you want to be all right
and ride motorcycles ride motorcycles
motorcycles are dope
my dad loves motorcycles attaboy all
right we'll talk to you later
thanks
you